abe's with us in fort lauderdale hi Abe
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
longtime listeners but unfortunately I
did not practice what you preach
and I'm in a bit of a situation I have
about seventy thousand dollars in credit
card debt which I have not made a
payment and I would say about two years
one just due to financials it just got
too much if I wasn't able to keep up
with the payments and I just let it go
what do you make a year oh okay
what's your household income XP a year
sixty okay
you have seventy thousand dollars in
credit card debt what other dad do you
have that's it you don't know anything
on your car no so you owe money on your
car how much do you owe on your car are
you there
come here okay how much do you owe on
the car thousand four thousand okay now
what your other debt do you have that's
it okay alright and what are you paying
rent 1450 are you single no married okay
how many kids or okay well it's time to
address this miss then what do you got
what are you basing today well American
Express is suing me right now for
sixteen thousand okay a lot of the
credit cards I'm them are charged up
some of them are about to do our jobs
mm-hmm okay they're suing you is that
because they said they were suing you or
you actually got served a lawsuit then I
got served and I got a letter in the
mail
he's my saying that they're having a
hearing when is the hearing May hey okay
all right well you're going to lose the
lawsuit right because you owe the money
and haven't paid it it's pretty simple
and they're going to take a judgment
against you that's not the end of the
world
you know from there what you're gonna
have to do is figure out how to settle
with them you know because obviously
this has gone way long and you're in to
build up some money to settle with them
you don't really have a dime today do
you I think that I have phase four
yes something like this and I I met your
your phone is breaking up try again I
couldn't borrow some money that's
obviously not idea right where would you
borrow money who would loan you my
friend I have a friend that would lend
me some oh no no no you don't need to
put your friend in American Express a
seat where they hate you all right all
right as you can't pay bills right now
you don't need to do that to a friend
so all right we've got to get you on a
detailed or written budget no life no
vacations no seeing the inside of a
restaurant you've been listening but now
you're gonna do it right yeah I kinda
have no choice yeah yeah you don't it's
time to get after this and you're scared
aren't you yeah for a long time and it's
just bouncing up and I kind of like
how's it affecting your marriage
all right not good you know yeah well
you don't feel real good about you and
she's scared to death and that's a
dangerous chemistry in a marriage so
here's what one day we're gonna put you
into Financial Peace University I'm
gonna pay for it because I've been where
you are scared and stupid I know exactly
how it feels okay and I'm going I'm
gonna walk with you brother you're gonna
make it out of this but you're gonna
save up money rapidly and then we're
gonna haul for American Express three or
four thousand dollars and they're gonna
take that as settlement on this judgment
it's not the end of the world we can
turn this around
you hang on I'll walk with you you're
gonna have to do it this time hold on